hello we hello neighbor
how are you doing today little day and
whoa what are you protesting I'm just
the most beautiful and elegant creature
ever seen Wow
bunnies are you I'm coming baby how you
like me now Barney Barney Barney do you
like Bonnie wait Barney do you like what
they did bunny bunny ow
Bonnie I got a longer tongue now honey
you're gonna come with me
this is this funny bunny I can hear your
screams of joy ow
just like that see you Bonnie it ain't
so bad it's good up here up in the sky
being taller way of doing everything I
don't even have Bonnie I know you having
a good time but please contain your
excitement yeah all your friends down
there let's go say hi to them hi
everybody
shut up Bonnie trying to do something oh
honey come here ow
Oh God Bonnie don't you yell at me I'm
trying my best here low bridge what did
you do why are you on fire
okay not gonna make that Bobby hold your
tits for two seconds we got to go up
holy intro flood how you did the
building know it suspect the thing that
me the tall goat that I am and supposed
to be here
is that uh something or other Oh looks
like it's up there oh that looks good
push hey Bonnie honey why did you
abandon me before come everybody we got
a places to be got things to see we got
places to go
hey wanna see a trick Wow how funny I
hope you know I do this for you I don't
do this for me I did this for you Wow
oh my god hey hey hi hi hi hi hey
Michael who's in front of a girl you
step out that's how it's gonna be
Bonnie you wait here I need to take care
of some things Oh what happened to you
Bonnie
okay your bone structure ow oh that's
how it's gonna be Oh God
you're a feisty one I got Rockets I
stepped out though oh wait i won
hey back off of me hey stop teaming up
on me what is this you douches I guess
my life tethered to a rock way over
there rocket guidance system activated
Wow it's okay
this is gonna leave my head over there
Stuart's okay good thing I got my head
no no my head is frozen literally in
place right there
that's normal I wanna go over here now
and cry myself to sleep does anyone have
a giant hydraulic press by which I could
stand under this is an experiment gone
horribly wrong I have a feeling I'll
never rectify this situation oh hey look
I fixed everything
Bowser problem officer allies come to me
over there and over there
maybe over here a little bit just let me
let me deal with my to do easy bruising
hello anybody seen it with demon goat
everybody seen Bonnie
has anybody seen Bonnie anybody see
Bonnie Bonnie I'm back baby
Bonnie I'm back no oh my god Bonnie
don't be like that baby you know you
love me
Bonnie back bonnie bonnie money money
money
bonnie bonnie you Suzie PAP no I didn't
say I need to sleep with you I just need
to speak with you that's what I'm in
wait a minute who's that who the hell
are you yeah you better run Bonnie of
our friends for you Bonnie lots of
friends Gabby now Bonnie are you happy
are you you happy you're happy man okay
hi Bonnie let's go down not in that way
but Louis's go down Allie Bonnie I need
to pick a fight with this guy this dudes
over here what hi you [ __ ] you want to
come over here I got you threw me out of
the ring
but I shall have my revenge back come
here [ __ ] oh god see now oh okay that's
what you got okay Bonnie Bonnie oh no I
lost Bonnie oh no whatever will I do
with my life
Allie and nail it
bonnie bonnie sees you and me oh yeah
Bonnie buddies is like that how do you
like that good buddy I know it's good
I know buddy no no do you run away from
me okay off we go into the sunset low
blow hi
oh hi oh hi I meant to do that
girls deliberate it was deliberate I got
a squeeze into this small hole have you
know what I mean
now like that you like my head outside
my body there we go got it nailed it
almost got it
Bonnie's bear with me Bonnie's been
there we go
Bonnie you didn't believe in me and look
where it got us now more than ever
bodies of cute that's a lot of boxes
Bonnie cut your crap I don't want to
hear any of it now I'm good
honey all of this is for you Oh Bobby I
may have done some to you where do you
think you're going Bonnie Bonnie okay my
demon power seem to be permanently stuck
on Bonnie but that's hardly an excuse
Bonnie don't make me get in there Bonnie
I've got a bone to pick with you Bonnie
I change for you I'd hate to think that
you wouldn't do the same so anyway that
was more goat simulator thanks everyone
for watching if you want to see more
leave a like down below and let me know
in the comments and as always